asked if he knows what islamic state
will do to him
the captured jordanian pilot's response
was brief
yes they will kill me
[Music]
[Laughter]
an english language online magazine run
by the terrorist group
interviewed muaf alka sasbe after his
plane came down
over northeast syria on the 24th of
december 2014
he'd been on a mission as part of an
international campaign against the
militants
when he suffered a mechanical failure or
if you believe the islamic state account
was shot down
either way it was a propaganda coup that
was brutally exploited
on the 3rd of february 2015 the
terrorists uploaded onto the internet
a slickly produced video of the 26 year
old pilot
trapped in a metal cage being burnt
alive
islamic state shocked the world when it
seized swathes of iraq and syria in 2014
viewing as an enemy anyone who didn't
believe their warped interpretation of
islam
this is sky news at five our top stories
iraqi soldiers in retreat as the
country's second city falls to hardline
islamic militants the superior manpower
and equipment of government forces
unable to easily overcome a militia with
a reputation for
extremes of violence they're living in a
new
state a caliphate the militants are now
in charge of
but this was not just a conflict fought
within their self-declared caliphate
it was also a global campaign of terror
and influence
waged across the gray zone of the
internet they were using it to
propagate their hateful ideology and
propaganda
and it was a very cheap and effective
way awaiting a terrorist warfare
islamic state seizure of physical
territory
triggered a very visible military
response from the united states the uk
and other allies less obvious
but just as important though was a range
of grey-zoned cyber offensives
that were also launched against the
group's online propaganda
social media posts even the digital
devices they used to communicate on the
battlefield
we prevented their propaganda
both through physical actions on the
battlefield but also
remotely getting to their servers
getting to the places that they stored
their material
the goal to make islamic state
go dark
[Music]
my name is debra haynes i'm the foreign
affairs editor at sky news
and you're listening to my podcast into
the gray zone
which explores a murky evolution of
warfare
i'll explain the covert tactics used by
states
criminals and terrorist groups to
deceive
gain influence and at times kill
this episode hears from the head of the
spy agency gchq
and a top general about how the uk
is using cyber to push back in the gray
zone
including new details about a major
cyber offensive against islamic state
but first i speak to a woman who was
once described as the uk's best
defensive cyber spy
[Music]
[Music]
my concern with the cyber environment is
at the moment we are good and noble but
we are losing
and we're losing because it's attacking
the unconventional the non-military
targets it's undermining our democracy
it's undermining our values
it's undermining our belief systems our
freedoms our press
it has the potential to undermine our
rule of law
and these are the things that we should
be thinking about
not around tanks battlefields and
world war ii this is sally walker she
spent the past 25 years
working for the government
communications headquarters better known
by its acronym
gchq it's the largest of the uk's three
main spy agencies
with the ability to access analyze and
on occasion
disrupt emails phone calls and other
forms of communication
she left gchq in 2020 and has decided to
speak publicly for the first time
from the viewpoint of being an ordinary
member of the public again
as opposed to a former spy her
motivation for breaking cover
is to help generate a debate about cyber
to start with sally says there needs to
be
a better understanding of what the word
cyber
actually means cyber is not online
cyber is use of the online environment
to change things in the real world
and whether it's real people that get
influenced or its malfunctions in real
technology
it is about what you can do from a
distance
at relatively low risk not necessarily
at low cost but definitely at low risk
you can have impact in the real world
and you can do it at scale this is such
an important point
i don't know about you but in the past
whenever i heard the word cyber
a part of my brain switched off because
i placed
all things cybery in this mysterious
domain of keyboards and codes
that i don't even pretend to understand
but what sally is saying is that boxing
cyber off
as some detached thing is missing the
point
cyber is merely the vector through which
large parts of our societies function
with a unique reach that spans from
bedroom to classroom
from company to care home an attack in
cyberspace
is by design meant to have an impact in
the real world
what's more while states criminals and
terrorists
use cyber against each other every day
in the gray zone
what constitutes a cyber operation is
also
a bit of a grey area itself
in the previous episode we looked at how
cyber can be used to cause
physical harm such as by turning off a
power grid
or holding hospital computers to ransom
but cyber operations in their broader
sense
also include activities that use digital
information
to influence a target population or
individual
this could be by secretly changing the
content of an email
or a text hacking and leaking files
or posting distorted information online
it makes for a very blurred line between
what is a cyber operation and what is an
information operation
most people who think about cyber
attacks they'll think about
uh kind of a a wannacry or a not pettier
or
some kind you know some kind of malware
that's put onto a computer but
from what you're saying that's obviously
part of it but also
um messages would you class that as a
sort of disinformation spread over
social media would you cast that as a
cyber attack
it's an area of huge contention um and
it's one of the
challenges for this whole space
um as to what con you know cyber is
i think is a term that can switch the
public off um it's also
disputed territory uh across various
communities because
you know is it is it the information is
that the data is the systems is it the
technology
um and and we could have that debate at
length and i'm not sure it would
get us anywhere i think if we bring it
back to
how do you undermine democracy then of
course false information is part of that
landscape who does it and who defends
against it
is important to work out but why we need
to defend against it is the most
important
part of the debate also important is why
hostile states
launch these kinds of attacks in the
first place it's because it's low risk
it's because it's attacking the things
that are otherwise difficult to attack
the foundations i think of democracy
free press um trust in law enforcement
uh some form of authority from our
institutions from our
uh from our way of operating
an academic freedom all of these things
that are
vital to us and less common
in other regimes
and uh ways of living
those are the things that are
threatening to our adversaries
and those are the things that they can
attack through cyber
the uk has the same kind of cyber
capabilities as russia
china iran or any of the other states
accused of conducting hostile operations
against british interests
but the uk government says it's
constrained in the way it pushes back
because it can only operate within the
rule of law
it's like being in a fight with someone
who's allowed to punch you repeatedly
below the belt
but you're not able to do the same back
because it would be a breach of your
values
that would of course put you at a
disadvantage
but if you consider just how fundamental
values such as the rule of law freedom
of expression
and human rights are to any liberal
democracy
then violating them to secure a
short-term gain
would do lasting damage over time
so you'd have to think of other ways to
stop the punches
so it means we're uniquely vulnerable
and that's why we need a different
debate
because everything about how we operate
everything about how law enforcement
operates everything about
how we go to war in a very constrained
ethical um legal framework everything
about how we conduct intelligence
operations in a very
legally constrained ethical proportional
framework
those are the very things that our
adversaries don't have to consider
but surely we can't say and therefore we
should give up i mean
we've always fought for what matters and
what matters is the freedom of the press
and our trust in law enforcement our
ability to use
the most sophisticated technology at the
cutting edge of our
economic prosperity these are the things
that matter but
if they matter to us we need to defend
them and we can't defend them by
sending boys and girls off to fight in
distant battlefields
um we might have to do that as well at
some distant point in the future who
knows but
but that can't be our our assumption
that this
that we will tolerate harm up until the
point that it becomes
uh justification for conflict
because the conflict is here and now but
it's it's a fight for ideas it's a fight
for influence
it's a fight for values
sally knows what she's talking about her
last job at gchq
was as director of cyber in that role
she was in charge of a top secret
program to hone the uk's ability to use
cyber offensively to attack adversaries
though sally doesn't like the terms
offense and defense
when describing such operations i do
think the offensive defensive language
is really
poor it implies i don't know some kind
of football game
where one side were attacking on one
side of defending and that isn't the
nature
of the contest or the conflict that we
face
she points out that in trench warfare no
one talks about
offensive and defensive bullets so why
does cyber get this special treatment
and offensive cyber capabilities are so
much more
than attacks there are knowledge of the
environment
knowledge of capabilities knowledge of
people
understanding global awareness
um and that feeds the system
that we need in order to protect
ourselves sally also opposes the way
talk about cyber is often framed in
relation to conflict
she specifically disagrees with a
suggestion by some experts
that hostile activity in cyberspace
could lead to a miscalculation
that escalates into an actual war i
think cyber warfare is attritional not
escalatory
you know if at its logical extension if
we were to go to war
through cyber the logical conclusion is
that everything stops
not that everything goes bang it's about
malfunctioning
technology uh and if stuff stops working
then as we've seen in all kinds of
scenarios
stuff just stops normal life just stops
but it's not the hollywood version where
it all gets blown up and
it just doesn't relate to uh
conventional warfare
so so i think framing cyber as a
as part of conflict while it's important
to the military and of course
the concept of going to war without
cyber capability is
not credible for the future but it
implies that this is
a defense issue and i don't think it is
i challenge her on that point because
wouldn't public outrage at a crippling
cyber attack
require a military response maybe you
can't unleash your
fast jets anymore if the cyber if if all
the satellites have been knocked out but
you do kind of go to war
i don't know it would have to be with
your bayonets at that point i suppose
i just think so it that that
um underestimates the human dynamic of
all of this and if
so if if my framing is correct and this
is a traditional
and it affects the human as well as the
technology
then our belief in authority
is diminished so who would go to war
because who gets to say that we should
and why are we doing it
and what is the cause that is such an
imperative
because i think the the subtlety the
sophistication of a cyber operation is
it saps
energy and the will to live we all know
what it feels like when our phones don't
work or our computers don't work we
don't look and think that's the russians
i hope
because it's probably not but it grinds
away at us
and in the end if trust is removed and
people stop
caring then our our motivation to act
is the very thing that is eroded through
a successful cyber operation that can
take
months years decades likely goes
undetected
and by the time we wake up and realize
that something precious has gone
it's too late to call for not just the
fast jets but just the very will of the
people
which is so vital to defence in going
into conflict that they do have that
support of the popul the civilian
population
there is disagreement among people who
work in defence and security circles
about whether or not cyber warfare is
attritional as sally says
or as escalatory but i guess that
underlines
why there's a need for a more public
debate about this whole area
the work sally did during her final
years at gchq
helped to shape a whole new approach by
the uk to cyber operations
the national cyber force was announced
by boris johnson
the uk's prime minister in november 2020
though it had already been operating
quietly for a number of months
in fact sally had been the designated
commander to lead the force
but she ended up leaving the civil
service before that happened
so another individual who has not been
publicly named
took charge instead the cyber force
is a new partnership between gchq and
the ministry of defence
as well as the secret intelligence
service mi6
and the defence laboratory at porton
down
your tech business is in a race to stay
ahead of the competition
and you might be wondering if china
could be your next move
but to work out whether china is the
right opportunity there are lots of
things you'll need to know
from customs compliance to cyber
security
to explore important questions like how
to protect your intellectual property
how chinese law might affect your
business and how to check the background
of potential business partners
visit gov dot uk forward slash digital
and tech china
see the potential know the challenge
i've got
jeremy fleming who is the director of
gchq
and general sir patrick sanders who is
the commander of
strategic command both on two separate
television screens speaking
to me from two separate locations the uk
is under a coronavirus lockdown
in january 2021 hence the strange setup
it's rare for a head of gchq to give an
interview
a sign perhaps of how the government is
keen for the public to understand
better the threats and opportunities
created by cyber
as well as why it needs a cyber force
which is my first question to the spy
chief
the uk is already a leading
responsible cyber power and we have that
status because we've invested very
heavily in the quality
of our defense over many years in our
cyber security
for over the last decade and it comes
from the strength of our tech sector and
it comes from
our uh uh reputation if you like our
track record
uh in in defense and uh intelligence and
more broadly but it's also clear that in
today's
world where technology prevalent and
where it affects all of our lives in our
in our private lives and in our
in our business lives that we need to be
able not only to defend
the digital homeland our our uh defend
the uk
we we need to be able to compete with
our adversaries we need to be able to
contest
in uh cyber space and do that in a way
which is
legal that is ethically responsible and
reflects our values as a country
that's where the cyber force comes in
how many people
are actually active members of this
force right now hasn't been disclosed
but the aim apparently is to grow it
into the thousands in the coming decade
it comprises a mix of gchq experts
and military personnel which is why
general sanders
is speaking in a virtual sense alongside
mr fleming
he had something called strategic
command which is a branch of the
military
that covers among other areas all things
cyber
can you just try and tell people what is
offensive cyber i mean what does it look
like
what does it do like how can you just
explain it in in terms that people could
understand
so it's not magic uh it's a combination
of
technology really clever technology and
people
and if i was trying to put this as
simply as i could and jeremy will
probably do this better than me
but i think of it as the deliberate
manipulation of
computer systems and data so that you
can achieve
real world objectives real world
outcomes
so those could be physical to where
cyberspace
connects to a piece of technology or
machinery in
in the military environment that means a
weapon system
but almost the more important use or
opportunities or threat that come from
cyber
is its ability to influence people and
that's a cognitive effect it has a
it has an impact on the way people think
and see the world and that's where
cyberspace connects to a human being
and can influence their behavior whether
that is through a phone
whether it's through a radio in the
military area or
display in a in an operations room so
we're using we're exploiting cyberspace
um to achieve real world outcomes and
real world effects and to protect
ourselves
his answer reinforces what we were
talking about earlier
about how cyber operations are so much
more than simply some malware on a
computer
in fact it seems the bigger opportunity
or threat
depending on whether you're the one
running the mission or being targeted by
it
is the ability to use cyber as a means
to influence people's minds
as we discovered in episode 2 what
better way to undermine a democracy
than to spread fake news online that
inflames divisions
on issues like race or politics
the uk's understanding of how to counter
this threat
is still evolving but it sounds as
though offensive cyber
will play a part is is defending
democratic processes from uh you know be
it
hostile state-backed hack and leak
campaigns uh or disinformation or other
kinds of
use of hostile cyber against us is that
an area where the national cyber force
could be and maybe has been used general
sanders again
so you've seen um i mean i think that
what's behind your question is
enormously important because what it
points to
and people tend to think about cyber
attacks in a hollywood sense about
closing down a power plant
or stopping a port from working in some
respects the most important the most
relevant
uh use of cyberspace is that the real
power is in influence
and not in sabotage and so what you're
seeing are
our adversaries our rivals exploiting
the tools that are meant to make for a
more utopian society so things like
social media
against us fueling conspiracy theories
and really sowing
division and tearing the fabric of
society apart and
you could go so far and describe it as
almost fueling a civil war inside some
of these societies
so when it comes to um to uh
to promoting the cohesion of society
and to protecting our democratic
processes
and countering the sort of hack and leak
examples that you described there
and yes offensive cyber is
unquestionably
one of the tools that is available to
government so we don't do this alone
you know the the lesson from 2016
where the russians hacked the uh the uh
the and interfered with the us elections
means that we work very closely
with uh other allies and partners not
least the us to protect
our democratic processes that does sound
like confirmation then that the uk
believes offensive cyber
has a part to play in protecting things
like elections
from hostile information attacks in the
gray zone
the kremlin has denied allegations of
interfering in the u.s election
another area of focus for the cyber
force is dealing with attacks by
criminals
it's a threat that's increased during
the pandemic with so many more people
going online while stuck at home
jeremy fleming we've also seen i'm going
to call this
out now a real rise in the in what's
known as ransomware
and this and this is where criminals are
are going
after poorly secured systems are
in effect taking hostage their
information or their systems and they're
seeking payment
financial advantage to get that data
back
and against the threat of of
promulgating that data
or releasing it more broadly on the
internet and we we have seen a real
increase
in ransomware both in the uk and
and globally the national cyber security
centre
which we focused on in the previous
episode and the national crime agency
have the lead for cybercrime but if it's
being launched from overseas
perhaps by an organized crime gang then
the cyber force could also help
but if we see a pattern in the use of
that ransomware if we
if we see a particular brand of
ransomware that we can
point to a particular adversary then the
national cyber force
is available for government uh working
alongside law enforcement
to to uh to to to contest that space
and that could include and has included
in the past going upstream
to uh to try and go after those groups
going upstream
in this context means when criminals are
operating beyond the reach of law
enforcement
it's possible for the uk to use cyber
capabilities
to disrupt or monitor their activities
instead
when you go upstream or when the data's
upstream or when the
capabilities upstream or when when you
think that there are serious organized
crime groups involved or potentially
in some contexts in the offensive
cyberspace
states involved then of course you have
to bring in bring to bear a whole range
of
of other capabilities too i see so
you're talking more about for example
like russian organized crime groups or
wherever foreign organized crime groups
are based overseas that's where you
your your skill the national cyber
forces skills are more useful there in
that context
i think inevitably we get pulled into
that space
it's quite hard for mr fleming and
general sanders to give
too much away as pretty much everything
the cyber force does
is top secret also a degree of ambiguity
is key for anyone operating in the gray
zone to keep opponents guessing
turning to the challenges posed by
states like russia and china
the military commander describes moscow
as an acute threat
and beijing as a chronic one general
garasimov who is the head of the russian
military
a few years ago said that the very rules
of war have changed
and the role of non-military means of
activity of achieving political and
strategic goals
has grown and in many cases they've
exceeded the power and force of weapons
in their effectiveness
so in this gray zone the most important
weapons don't necessarily fire
bullets and i'd say that they they don't
and then the chinese
have a concept of unrestricted warfare
and this is their doctrine where they
use all means to compel the enemy to
accept one's interests and that's trade
wars
foreign aid assistance cyber and
information warfare
and capturing control of key
technologies so what we're seeing is
that the use of of cyberspace is one of
a number of things
that our our rivals our adversaries are
are weaponizing to try to achieve
strategic advantage
in their own interests and to change the
nature of the international rules-based
system
in a way that that gradually pre-empts
and achieves a fetter complete which
leaves us weaker
this is exactly why understanding the
gray zone really matters
because as we heard in episode 1
literally anything
can be and is used as a weapon
at risk for liberal democracies is a
framework of rules and institutions
formed following the end of the second
world war to uphold rights
freedoms and security it's what general
sanders is talking about
when he refers to the rules-based
international system
but this is not a one-way street the uk
and its allies are clearly pushing back
in the gray zone too
i asked mr fleming whether the uk has
used offensive cyber operations
against china or russia or another
hostile state
well you would you wouldn't want us to
to go into
the detail of our operations but what
what i will say is that the
the uk hasn't has hesitated and in many
respects as
has led led the way with some key allies
in calling out behaviors when they have
overstepped
the lines that we have set the gchq
director
is talking about the public attribution
of cyber attacks that we covered in
episode four
i try asking the question again so are
you able to confirm that we have used
offensive cyber
against a state at some point well we're
able to say that it's
available to governments to use in that
context so
that's not a no and what about the range
of cyber weapons in the uk's arsenal
but can you just sort of say like is
there a spectrum like you know in the
military there's obviously a spectrum of
different weapons
uh from a rifle all the way up to a
trident missile
like in in when you look at your suite
of cyber offensive weapons
is it the same other like sort of you
know sort of small kind of tactical
um cyber weapons all the way up to
strategic
potentially cyber weapons of mass
destruction general sanders
so i i wouldn't want to pick up on that
or let you get away with that phrase of
cyber weapons and mass destruction
um and and i don't want to go i don't
really want to go into specifics but
but you're right to observe that we
would expect we would use
um the tools that we have and the
techniques and the expertise
we have to across that full range
from the strategic where we're
protecting ourselves
in cyberspace from from threats that
could
get after our critical national
infrastructure right the way through to
uh use of it on the battlefield to
influence for example
communications and that's nothing new
you know
we've used uh electronic warfare
to disrupt uh our enemies communications
in the past and there's no reason why we
wouldn't do that in cyberspace as well
so i came in on this question uh too
because
obviously patrick's right to say that we
we are very cagey about
going into the detail of our operations
for for uh obvious
uh reasons but we have uh i made an
example i think
of uh of the uk in being a able to
describe and being
open in describing the regime which
governs their use but also the
sorts of the sorts of um operations that
we can mount
the gchq director sets out a sliding
scale
of different types of offensive cyber
operations in the uk's remit
from dealing with criminals up to actual
war
uh we we might deploy capabilities to
counter individual
uh criminals or serious and organized uh
crime
gangs and that that could include you
know getting onto their phones or the
technology there
they are using he means doing things
like
and this is an educated guess because he
didn't give specifics
hacking and stealing or deleting data or
locking someone out of their account
or making it impossible for them to use
their phone
the next category is to deter or to stop
adversaries from attacking the uk
by getting at them first with malware to
disrupt
or to monitor their online activities
you might have heard the
the uh the expression defending forward
or persistent engagement
now that is uh having it available as a
tool to to go after those who are
seeking to do
damage to our in our cyber um
environments
we might use it to counter
misinformation and disinformation
and of course that's a very live theme
at the moment isn't it internationally
another role for the cyber force is to
be part of any retaliation
to a grayzone style attack against the
uk
and not one necessarily that came from
cyberspace
and we might use it to respond to to
impose costs if you like
where the aggregate effect below the
threshold that
might ordinarily be considered conflict
if you like what this whole podcast is
about the gray zone
you know how would we respond to some of
those activities in an aggregate fashion
and
then the national cyber force is
available to government
uh to do that too the final area for
cyber
is as part of a military operation so a
mobile phone at one end
uh preventing and influencing the use of
the internet by our adversaries in the
middle
and then alongside patrick in the
military in a
in a uh in a conflict type situation too
both men are keen to stress that cyber
is primarily a force for good in the
world
powering economies and connecting people
but they're very aware of the need
for new rules to be agreed
internationally that govern hostile
cyber activity
in the gray zone the more the broader
strategic piece for me is
you know what sort of conversation do we
want to have about the use of these
capabilities and the the uh the law
and the governance and the regulations
governing uh cyberspace and
there are broadly two polar different
views and surprise surprise they come
down the same lines as
as between states that we might consider
to be you know those we're contesting
our adversaries and those who who are
friendly and and we have to we have to
make progress on that
the uk's use of offensive cyber
capabilities
is so secret that the government has
only ever avowed one mission
even though it's inconceivable there
haven't been more
especially given everything we've just
heard the publicly acknowledged
operation
was against the terrorist group islamic
state in 2014
it seized control of large parts of iraq
and syria
in a frenzy of slaughter and terror
this is sky news good evening iraqi
government forces have been forced out
of the country's second largest city
leaving an entire province in the hands
of hardline islamic militants
isis or simply islamic state as the
group now wants to be called
use the internet and social media to
deliver its potent message
in june of that year abu bakr
al-baghdadi the then leader
declared the creation of a caliphate
stretching from the iraqi city of mosul
to the syrian city of raqqa
the united states the uk and other
allies
launched a military campaign to help
local forces on the ground
combat the militants but islamic state
wasn't just fighting within its newly
claimed territory
[Music]
in a first for a terrorist organization
it also weaponized the global gray zone
of the internet
to draw in thousands of recruits with
online propaganda
filled with the promise of a better life
in the caliphate it's a real reflection
as to how the very character of conflict
uh is changing tobias ellwood a
conservative mp
and chair of the defence select
committee in parliament
was a foreign office minister from 2014
to 2017.
you go back to how osama bin laden would
talk to the world
he would hand a vcr cassette you know to
cnn who would then plug it in and that
would be the messaging
and now because of social media because
of the digital world that's now grown
the terrorist organizations are able to
do it themselves islamic states
online messaging helped convince large
numbers of men
women even children to travel to syria
and iraq
including from the uk may i ask
what was it that attracted you was it
from watching videos was there somebody
or
who recruited you were cleric who
recruited you what was it that
prompted a 15 year old girl to go to
syria
during the time i left you know dollar
was on the news and stuff and like a lot
of videos were coming out and i
saw the videos on the internet and that
just kind of attracted me to them
like it attracted a lot of people
shamima begum
is one of three school girls from
bethnal green in east london
who left their homes and traveled
together to syria in 2015
she was talking to my colleague john
sparks four years later
at a displacement camp in the country
after islamic state
which she refers to as al daola was
finally pushed out of all the territory
it had seized
the young woman had just given birth to
a son
who later died he was her third child
lost to this conflict
in their recruitment drive the terrorist
group's media wing
posted videos of battlefield victories
filmed by its equivalent of a combat
cameraman
or by using drone footage
a more targeted approach was also used
with islamic state fighters
taking to social media and messaging
apps like telegram
to woo men and women to join their cause
it made the group a particularly
unconventional challenge for the uk
and its allies we did some very careful
analysis
about how we might deal with this
unusual threat
and what that analysis told us was that
daish were using in the way that you've
described cyber technology as a strength
general sanders is using the arabic
acronym for islamic state
which is daesh they were using it to
propagate their hateful ideology and
propaganda but they were using it for
coordination for command and control
for attack planning to maintain the
morale and the cohesion
of their own forces and it was a very
cheap and effective way
of waging a terrorist warfare he means
that as well as using technology as a
recruitment tool
islamic state used their phones and
other devices
to communicate with each other on the
battlefield and what we wanted to do was
to turn
that strength that dependence that they
had on the cyber into a vulnerability
and also to undermine the credibility of
their information campaign
and of their ideology he's describing
two
different dimensions to this cyber
effort both very secret
and both testing out new cyber
techniques
it's the first time the uk has spoken
about these operations in such detail
one effort was a major long-running gray
zone zone-style campaign
also involving the americans that went
after the terrorist use of digital
information
to recruit fighters and build support
the other
was more about how cyber can be used on
the battlefield
alongside more obvious weapons like
artillery rounds and airstrikes
jeremy fleming talks about the
borderless mission to hunt islamic state
online
so there definitely was a sense at the
time that that the
the the reach of this propaganda and its
effectiveness was something that we had
to counter and we had to counter it
uh where it was being produced alongside
that that area of of conflict but we
also
had to um combat it strategically
we had to be going after the ways in
which that propaganda
was being uh promulgated itself we had
to
make sure that we were using all of our
defensive armory to stop it getting
through
the uk's goal was to make islamic state
go dark
by taking its propaganda offline and
degrading the ability of its media wing
to put out things like that english
language online magazine i mentioned at
the start
which was called dabiq the mission also
targeted the group's activities over
social media
you know the conversations we're having
at the moment about uh the
roles and responsibilities of service
providers for the content on their
platforms
that that really started in that sort of
period
alongside their conversation on on on
child sexual exploitation but it was
this feeling of
so if this material is getting through
then how do we counter that
the answer he says was a combination of
working with governments
and the big tech companies like twitter
and facebook
to get extremist material taken down
coupled with offensive cyber operations
targeted at anything that was harder to
reach
we prevented their propaganda you know
both through physical
actions on the battlefield but also
remotely getting
to their servers getting to the places
that they stored their material
physical actions on the battlefield mean
things like
launching an airstrike to destroy an
islamic state building
used by those involved in generating the
propaganda
going after the servers though is much
more in the cyber realm
and means targeting data held on servers
often in different countries around the
world
with a view to deleting the content or
using malware
to lock islamic state out of their own
files
much of this work was carried out from
gchq's headquarters
in cheltenham in the uk thousands of
miles away from the self-declared
caliphate
a reminder of the global nature of
greyzone warfare
the effect of this operation can be seen
with a simple google search
back in 2014 or 2015 any number of
horrific videos
would have popped up on your screen
facebook and twitter
were also awash with pro-islamic state
messages
not so today of course islamic state
hasn't gone dark as there are plenty of
corners of the internet where they're
still able to spread their influence
messaging apps with end-to-end
encryption and a self-delete function
also mean they can continue to exploit
technology to communicate
but there's no doubt the terrorist
group's ability to reach into people's
minds
has been reduced as for how cyber was
used on the battlefield
it was part of a covert mission
involving officers from gchq
and british special forces who are
operating in the region
in support of iraqi troops and syrian
democratic fighters
general sanders explains so we wanted to
ensure that when they tried to
coordinate attacks on our forces their
devices didn't work
but they couldn't trust the orders that
were coming to them from their seniors
we wanted to deceive them
and to misdirect them to make them less
effective less cohesive
and sap their morale but you can't just
do that in cyberspace
you have to coordinate and integrate
that with activities that are going on
on the ground whether it's from our own
forces special forces and others
whether it's with the iraqi military
whether it's with the opposition
and whether it's with the resistance
movements that grew up in mosul
and so we were able to use cyberspace in
a coordinated way
to attack and undermine daesh to
strengthen
the resistance of people who are
standing up to daish
and coordinate it with strikes and the
results
you saw play out in front of you it was
a very very effective
use of cyber tools combined with
other operations uh in a broader
coalition
and can you just talk a bit more about
what you meant when you said that they
their devices wouldn't work like what
like
sort of their laptops and their mobile
phones can you just spell out what you
mean by that
um they either couldn't trust the
messages that were coming to them
or they weren't working well the devices
weren't working
yes mr fleming also describes the
operation
we tactically disrupted the
communication
of uh daishi's fighters on the
battlefield
you know at times that and they that
gave the military commanders the element
of surprise enabled them to
to adopt a different posture in that
combat
in planar english what happened is that
cyber capabilities
were used for example to stop islamic
state commanders
from being able to send messages with
instructions to their foot soldiers
or to alter the content of these
messages meaning militants
might be tricked into heading in the
wrong direction and getting killed
there's also evidence that some fighters
no longer able to send or receive
messages
felt so cut off and isolated that they
simply dumped their weapons and left the
battlefield
another islamic state device the uk went
after with offensive cyber
was their ability to use armed drones we
we piloted some really early
technologies to disrupt daesh's use of
some pretty
basic drone technology but which was
causing us
a problem and just so i understand when
you talk about how you you managed to
use some new innovative techniques to
disrupt these drones that were causing
issues
is that like is that sort of code for
you you use some kind of cyber element
to disrupt the drones or
is that what you're trying to say yes
you reached a red line there obviously
and uh you know we
cyber techniques to affect how a drone
operated
there's one final area the gchq chief
talks about
which is to do with using messages to
help keep local people safe
who were living inside the self-declared
caliphate but didn't support islamic
state
again evidence about how the line
between cyber operation
and information operation is a very gray
blurry one
we delivered thousands of humanitarian
messages to those affected by
daesh in their immediate environment to
help the local
population understand what's going on to
help them protect
themselves i ask both men what the
campaign against islamic state would
have looked like
if cyber power hadn't been used general
sanders answers first
it would have been very much harder this
was
uh what this did was to create the
conditions
for daishi's physical defeat by
very very brave and resilient iraqi
security forces supported by the
coalition
it would have uh it would have taken a
lot longer it would have been a lot
bloodier
and it probably would have led to um
that expansion of daesh's ideology
and its caliphate outside of the
immediate regions
that we were engaged in into other parts
of
north africa and the middle east so this
had both a suppressive effect it also
accelerated
the defeat and the containment of daesh
and it made
it made the operations still hard though
they were
much easier for uh our allies our
partner forces who were actually
fighting them on the ground
jeremy fleming again and and i think it
sends a sent a really strong signal that
we and our allies we're not going to
leave
uh cyberspace as an uncontested place
you know we we have to we have to defend
it
uh we have to make sure it's as secure
as possible we have to make sure that it
is
still underpinning our commerce our
economy
our society and our communities but but
equally when
adversaries like daesh overstep the line
then they need to expect us to contest
it too
and and if you like what you saw in iraq
and around that
conflict was was not only the first
conflict that was played out in the full
glare of
everything that the internet uh has
available and the
the the the advantages it has in terms
of
of moving information and making and
making the world aware of what's
happening but it but also
of understanding that it's a place that
can be misused and when it is we will we
will step in to
to help adjust address that situation
crucially the operation against islamic
state
shows how cyber power can be used to
counter one of the most
insidious dimensions of the gray zone
the weaponization of information to
influence minds
whether that's to radicalize someone to
become a terrorist
or to undermine a democracy by say
eroding trust in elections
it's a reminder that cyber attacks are
by no
means just about making machines
malfunction with a clever piece of code
they are fundamentally about humans
using cyberspace
as a means to affect how we all think
act
feel what we believe what we doubt
who and what we trust it means the
military and spy agencies
even with their new cyber force can't
possibly hope to protect the uk
from the full range of cyber threats
alone
instead just like with climate change
or fighting back against the coronavirus
pandemic every single person
has a part to play in protecting
themselves in the cyber gray zone
from updating antivirus software to
checking the provenance of the
information you read
coming up iraq is the battleground
in a battle that it has no part of iraq
is not at war with the us iraq is not at
war with iran
yet iraq is where it all happens
uh this is why i i thought my country
was
being kidnapped but that's next time
as we continue into the gray zone
into the gray zone is a sky news podcast
it was edited and produced by chris
scott
with production support from michael
greenfield and narrated by me
debra haynes the head of sky news radio
is dave terrace
listen and subscribe wherever you get
your podcasts